[Music]
so you wake up in the morning and the
only thing you want is a cup of coffee
the last thing in the world you want to
do is go to Starbucks and stand in line
and pay too much money for somebody to
get your order wrong and have to make it
11 more times before they get it right
that's what mrs. Mensa saw this is cafe
X and it's an industrial robot whose job
it is to make you coffee as perfectly
and quickly as it possibly can you can
order from your phone or from a kiosk
and the goal is to put it everywhere
where there's lots of people who need
coffee right now you have a bunch of
different coffee options you can pick if
you want some syrup and then you give it
your phone number
and what this will do is it'll tell you
when your order is about to be made and
when it's ready so you can just walk
right through pick it up and later they
can make a coffee in about 20 seconds
it's really fast and it's running two
machines at the same time it's designed
to be super efficient so lots of people
can get in and out really quickly
I guess I'm saying my coffees ready so
my pin is 6 3 4 9 and there's my coffee
so the idea is that most people will
order from their phone they really want
repeat customers who can just sort of
run in and out they're gonna put these
things in train station so you can just
grab one quickly as you go so you can
set this to be ready at a time that you
want I have to say there's only one
downside really is that a latte art kind
of leaves a lot to be desired but
otherwise it's pretty delicious
[Music]